if i said the word synthetic you'd
probably think the nice pristine white
polyester lab coat
if i said the words biology you'd likely
think of life and cells
put the two together
and you get synthetic biology
but as we'll see in this video synthetic
biology is about harnessing the power of
nature to solve problems in medicine
manufacturing and agriculture
and i think that's marvelous
so sounds pretty important which is why
we will take an intro in this video into
synthetic biology in particular
synthetic gene circuits and how they
could be applied to speed up drug
discovery by using cellular
reprogramming as a case study
so first then what is really meant by
synthetic biology and what are synthetic
gene circuits
well firstly it's the realization and
appreciation that cells and groups of
cells are really quite clever
clever and that they possess systems
that enable them to respond to
information in their external and
internal environment
extract that data and then interpret it
to adjust their behavior in space and
time
pretty impressive and so synthetic
biology
as nicely described here aims to develop
tools that tap into these native
networks and dynamically access
information in the cell
synthetic gene circuits then
enable real-time monitoring of diverse
molecular events and live cells
so it sounds pretty cool but before we
get to that let's just take a little
step back because at least for me right
now it's a saturday morning and i like
to keep things quite chill so if you've
been following this channel for a while
then you know i study a pretty cool
protein called p53 and if you're new
then hello my name's helena and i like
this protein
and what p43 does is it binds to dna and
it activates a specific subset of genes
p53 does this when it's active
given that p53 is pretty important it's
of interest to know when p53 is active i
could do that by using a reporter system
i could put a p53 binding site upstream
of a reported gene so it could be a
fluorescent protein
such that when p53 is active it binds to
the site activates this reported gene
and then i can look at my cells and go
hey this one's green it therefore has
active p53
so this is a form of synthetic biology
it's a tool that enables me to access
information from the cell p53 is active
but this is really just scratching the
surface of what may be possible
the next step up from these simple
reporter systems are synthetic gene
circuits
instead of having a direct readout of my
p53 activity an enhanced version could
have in quotes here amplifier genes that
get expressed that then enhance this
dynamic range of p53 activity and may
offer extra sensitivity
and this is because there are inherent
limitations with the current reporter
systems
another one being that it just has one
p53 binding site and there are many
variations within what a p53 binding
site might be
and therefore there is information that
is lost synthetic gene circuits could be
built to condense signals from multiple
gene regulatory networks into a single
output
and you can also build in repressors to
the system to increase the signal to
noise ratio
all to increase the amount of
information and the accuracy of the
information that i can get from the cell
and so i suppose what i like about these
synthetic gene circuits is that they
enable creativity you couldn't theory
design what you want
i mean well obviously it might not work
you need good designs and that's where
more of the engineering expertise comes
in
but anyway this p53 aspect is more of a
weird niche that maybe i'm interested in
but what about something else something
of a hot topic right now i don't know
you say cellular reprogramming
rejuvenation
well yes synthetic biology for sure will
have potential hair too
and in fact in many ways you could say
cellular reprogramming is a form of
synthetic biology
you are adding in factors to a cell and
forcing a cell to do something different
which we think will cause them to become
stem cells
in this case overexpressing the
so-called yamanaka factors
oct4 sox2 klf4 and mic
as demonstrated by shinya yamanaka
flashback in 2006
to convert differentiated cells into
induced pluripotent stem cells
these stem cells have the capability to
replicate or differentiate into other
cell types
and so they're not only useful for
disease modelling of human cells that
are hard to access like neurons but also
have potential in regenerative medicine
but in reality the bioengineering is not
perfect yet here and not all of the
cells given these factors become induced
pluripotent stem cells
so how can we use alternative synthetic
biology approaches to make this more
sophisticated
well ultimately we have a phenotype that
we're interested in stem cells and we
want to test a variety of different
therapeutic strategies
and using these different synthetic gene
circuits could be built to try and speed
up that process
to increase the signal-to-noise ratio
and to overcome some of the limitations
that we currently see with cellular
reprogramming
and to quote from this review article
ageing represents an important
determinant of disease onset and fevo
that remains challenging to assess in
living cells as age cells display
defects in metabolism nuclear structure
which can inform the development of
reporters and circuits for example you
could design a reporter
to aid in the identification of cells
that have successfully reprogrammed
and then i guess another area of
interest in the aging field is treating
neurodegenerative diseases such as
alzheimer's disease
and most that set up for debate as to
what the exact causes of these diseases
are
one of the hallmarks of them is the
presence of protein aggregates and guess
what you can build a gene circuit that
enables the expression of reporters in a
cell when there are aggregates of
proteins
and so you could then use the system to
screen for drugs that prevent
aggregation
and so whilst this video has been a
brief introduction to synthetic gene
biology there is much to unpack and much
that i'm trying to unpack myself as i
learn more about this area
but that said i did make an entire video
showing how crispr can be used to
reprogram cells which is like got
synthetic biology written all over it
so to learn about this approach be sure
to watch this video here
so with that i hope you've learned
something in this video thank you to my
patreon supporters and thank you for
listening